[Música]
i
bienvenidos a europa hoy el programa de
actualidad europea de france 24 en
español yo soy este de redactar o desde
el parlamento europeo en bruselas es un
placer saludarles en el programa de hoy
abordamos la grave crisis alimentaria
que se está empezando ya a notar muy
especialmente en el continente africano
como consecuencia de la guerra no crank
ya cuáles son las causas y consecuencias
y las soluciones antes de pasar al
debate con nuestras invitadas vemos cuál
es la situación actual y por qué hay que
estar muy atentos a esta crisis el mundo
mira con preocupación como las
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania
pueden acelerar una crisis mundial de
alimentos rusia y ucrania exportan
alrededor del 50 por ciento de los
cereales que necesitan en el norte de
áfrica y oriente próximo el este de
áfrica es aún más dependiente y casi su
totalidad de importaciones de granos
dependen de moscú y kiev la unión
europea y la onu advierten que el
bloqueo en los puertos y bombardeo de
almacenes de cereales durante la guerra
en ucrania pueden provocar hambrunas sin
precedentes
más de 200 millones de personas dependen
de que el grano y los cereales se
exporten de estos países según las
autoridades ucranianas más de 20
millones de toneladas de trigo están
bloqueadas sin poder salir por todo ello
los precios de los alimentos no paran de
subir las consecuencias de la guerra se
notan a kilómetros de distancia se ha
reducido la exportación de fertilizantes
de la que también depende en gran parte
de países de américa latina rusia a
instancias de turquía se ha comprometido
a movilizar el trigo bloqueado siempre
que define la zona del puerto de odessa
en cualquier caso bruselas recuerda que
no hay sanciones a los productos
agrícolas y que los cereales se pueden
exportar cuando las partes decidan
y para poder conocer más de cerca qué es
lo que está ocurriendo en las posibles
soluciones contamos con las
eurodiputadas clara aguilera del grupo
social de bienvenida clara muchas
gracias
igualmente y con soraya rodríguez del
grupo renovar europa bienvenidas ahora y
una vez más buenas tardes bienvenidos a
las dos me gustaría empezar rápidamente
primero de todo con un fax checking
porque rusia culpa a la unión europea de
que los cereales no pueden salir porque
la unión europea ha aplicado sanciones a
los productos agrícolas ya los
fertilizantes rusos que hay de verdadero
o de falso en esta afirmación soraya
falso
es una mentira más de las que con las
que putin y su gobierno criminal está
afrontando esta guerra desinformación y
mentiras
indudablemente nosotros hemos
en este último quinto paquete de
sanciones también hemos ampliado o
sanciones a ciertos fertilizantes que
han entrado en vigor ayer o antes de
ayer el 10 de julio llevamos
efectivamente viendo una situación de
inseguridad alimentaria en el mundo muy
muy grande
tiene efectivamente su causa en esta
invasión criminal que afecta a dos
países que son llamados los graneros del
mundo más del 30% del cereal del 50% de
la colza eso está distorsionando
claramente el mercado alimentario
mundial afecta incluso a la unión
europea donde prácticamente somos
autosuficientes en prácticamente toda la
producción pero aumenta el precio de la
gasolina el precio del diésel y está
afectando de forma gravísima a países
que dependen de la ayuda alimentaria o
que dependen en gran porcentaje de sus
exportaciones es de toda esta situación
sólo hay un responsable que se llama
putting invasión criminal y su gobierno
solo una cosa para que se vea esta
mentira
los rusos el ejército ruso putin está
robando cereal de ucrania más de 600.000
toneladas están saliendo camino de rusia
esta es la verdadera situación por lo
tanto no no hay ningún responsable en la
unión europea el responsable está fuera
si nos permite y unido a lo que ha dicho
coincidido el cien por cien en lo que he
hecho sólo haya unido a esto yo creo que
es esa es la estrategia de putin es
decir utilizar eso es falso
absolutamente él ha explicado muy bien
soraya pero quiere utilizar eso y quiere
además él es consciente de que va a
provocar sobre todo en países africanos
y también asiáticos va a provocar una
hambruna
horrorosa con lo cual yo creo que es
consciente de esta situación que está
provocando para que al final de todos
ellos países ir provocando una salida de
gen débil yo creo que tiene una doble
intencionalidad parte de la mentira del
engaño de desabastecer a los mercados a
través de el daño que está haciendo a la
propia ucrania de su gente robando cómo
estás diciendo producción y permitiendo
que no salga producción por eso esos
corredores con ucrania para que no salga
cereales ni otros productos de la propia
planea quiere provocar va a ser el
culpable principal y único del hambre en
muchos países que eso es una cuestión
absolutamente lamentable que alguien
pueda utilizar esa circunstancia
justamente
vemos que se acerca una hambruna
gravísima como comentabas aclara también
esto se añade a la inflación que
dificulta también que la población pueda
acceder a los alimentos según el banco
mundial por cada vez que se sube un
punto porcentual la inflación 10
millones de personas caen en pobreza
extrema puede el mundo acercarse a una
hambruna sin precedente es peor que la
del 2008 claro sí yo creo que
estamos muy cerca a esa situación lo
dicen además los responsables de la fao
que conocen y trabajan en todo el mundo
nos vienen anunciando
que esta situación se puede provocar ya
se está dando pero no sabemos cuándo va
a acabar la guerra ni cómo va a acabar y
por lo tanto esto hay una situación de
una hambruna que puede ser la más grande
que hayamos conocido decir superiora de
2008 por lo tanto imagínate la de gente
que estaría en esa situación por eso
todo tan doloroso que se utilicen las
mentiras el engaño esta invasión con esa
situación no es decir la fao y los los
viene denunciando esa situación estamos
ante una gravedad tremenda y por lo
tanto hasta ahora nosotros en europa no
hemos tenido problemas somos bastante o
suficientes aunque no tanto en
oleaginosas y otros productos pero bien
somos bastante autosuficientes pero
tenemos que abordar probablemente en el
mundo esa esa hambruna que no nos caiga
nos cae a todos es decir porque eso
seguro en una situación insostenible y
de una hambruna sin precedentes hay que
encontrar varias soluciones la comisión
europea ha propuesto vías rápidas de
transporte para poder transportar los
cereales desde ucrania hasta el
continente europeo pero está siendo
bastante difícil vemos que también se ha
abierto ya una ruta en el mar báltico de
hecho algunos cereales cereales y han
llegado a españa se ha propuesto
movilizar 500 millones de euros para el
continente africano es esto suficiente
que otras medidas se pueden se pueden
hacer bueno la verdad es que tenemos una
el efecto de la guerra el efecto en
países muy lejanos
está siendo ya terrible no
más de 180 millones de personas estaban
en una situación de inseguridad
alimentaria grave antes de la guerra
ante 19 millones de personas más se
pueden sumar en este año 2023 porque por
falta de alimentos
hay que incrementar la ayuda humanitaria
pero sobre todo tenemos que tener
disponibilidad de alimentos cómo podemos
realmente desbloquear esta guerra del
hambre que abierto putin una guerra del
hambre como las que se hacían en el
siglo pasado
bloqueando sus puertos bloqueando las
salidas del mar negro
hay que tener en cuenta que es muy
difícil sustituir lo que sale del mar
negro salían
entre
2030 y 40 millones de toneladas de grano
de cereales que podrían alimentar a más
de 400 millones de personas como podemos
sacar eso por vía terrestre la comisión
europea se ha puesto a puesto a diseñar
alternativas a sacarlo a través de
carretera a través de camiones podemos
en este caso agilizar mecanismos
administrativos
agilizar las fronteras de la unión
sanitarios pero por ahí podemos sacar
muy poco las vías a través de
ferrocarriles tampoco nos sirven porque
el ancho de vía ucrania no es diferente
al ancho de vía que utilizamos en la
unión europea por lo tanto
necesitamos el desbloqueo
en los puertos en el mar negro
el bloqueo le está efectuando
putin y en esta situación la falta de
trigo de cereal de cebada en los
mercados internacionales afecta
claramente al programa mundial de
alimentos que es el que da directamente
asistencia alimentaria a países que ya
venían sufriendo la antes de la guerra
me estoy refiriendo a países como yemen
a países como afganistán
siria sudán que antes de la guerra ya
necesitaban la asistencia alimentaria
por eso el desbloqueo
es necesario
no tengo mucha confianza en que esto
pueda hacerlo putin ha entrado a
utilizar el hambre como un arma de
guerra va a seguir bloqueando el mar
negro todo lo que pueda dejando que se
pudra el cereal en los almacenes que
están también dentro del territorio
ucraniano no olvidemos que más del 42
por ciento hoy de la población ucraniana
no tiene acceso a los alimentos esto
está siendo terrible pero necesitamos el
desbloqueo de los puertos del mar negro
para poder abastecer al mercado nacional
en el encuentro con el vice ministro
ucraniano
nos decían que estaban intentando ese
bloqueo en el mar mar negro mencias y
para ellos estaba convirtiéndose en
clave el puerto de constanza en rumanía
ni porque como bien ha dicho en
carretera sólo transportaban el 10 por
ciento sólo con lo cual pensar ahora que
en las salidas de carretera pueden
incrementarse pero
así el 90% salía por puerto y por otras
vías
el transporte de mercancías de
ferrocarril imposible el ancho de
distintos y el puerto de constanza puede
convertirse en una aspiración y parece
ser que ahí se está trabajando en esa
línea nos queda apenas un minutos ahora
ya pero no quiero acabar sin preguntar
sobre también las consecuencias
migratorias que puedes tener está
también está esta crisis alimentaria
porque también puede estar utilizando
las personas para provocar también una
presión migratoria hacia la usando la
invención indudablemente la presión
migratoria se va a aumentar cuando en
muchos países la gente no reciba ayuda
alimentaria en países donde ya está
recibiendo va a haber movimientos de
población a países vecinos
para encontrar alimento va a haber mucha
tensión social y países que no viven de
la asistencia alimentaria pero por
ejemplo egipto
importa el 80% del cereal va a ver como
el incremento de este producto básico
para sus ciudadanos se va a ver
incrementado porque hay menos y subirá
el precio por lo tanto la inestabilidad
social también incrementará las
consecuencias de esta invasión criminal
de putin tienen consecuencias globales
no va a haber ningún país por muy lejos
que se sienta de ucrania que se vea
ajeno a las consecuencias de esta guerra
pero eso no cabe otra a la guerra hay
que pararla y para parar la guerra hay
que parar a su autor hay que parar a
putin gracias ahora ya gracias clara
lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo pero vamos a estar muy pendientes
de esta crisis a ustedes les esperamos
en el próximo programa de europa hoy
gracias por ver france24 en español
[Música]